I think we could start with something
that may the audience may not understand
why that these two things are together
but the beginning of your career was
really in engineering and film criticism
correct that's correct I was an
engineering major at Stanford and I was
writing for the Stanford daily and I
found out that the film critics they had
to film critics for the daily got free
passes to all the theaters in Palo Alto
so I wrote a couple of sample reviews
and they took me on and I started
looking at films more it was more detail
and I decided I didn't want to be an
engineer I wanted to work in films but I
was a senior and I figure I'll get the
degree and get out of here so do you
recall what what kinds of films you were
seeing and and and and obviously they
they influenced your your filmmaking I
saw all kinds of films I remember
particularly a John Ford classic western
My Darling Clementine which was a
brilliant film and I probably I gave
that the best review of any film I saw I
mean as your career went on and you
there were there were ups and downs was
there ever a moment where you said all
this film business is for the birds I
should have stuck with the engineering
at the beginning yes I couldn't get a
job anywhere off the studios were highly
unionized and you couldn't really break
in and there was almost no independent
work so i finally said okay I'll be an
engineer I went to work for us
electrical motors on Monday and I quit
on Thursday they told me at the head of
the personnel said Roger don't be hasty
come back to work on friday think about
it on the weekend and then make your
decision on monday and i said i really
cannot come back tomorrow with four days
is that that was good that you actually
saw the grass was not any greener on the
engineering side well as Randy pointed
out drive-ins have 0
been part of your career but I wanted to
to hear a little bit more about the the
21st century iteration of the drivin
that you created one of the first online
streaming channels that was called
Corman's drivin you are still blazing
new distribution channels for your films
in your library can you talk about how
that came about yes we decided to start
our own channel gordmans drive again it
did well for a couple of years and then
we got offers from bigger entities than
we realize we could make more money
going with the majors than going with
our own well and so when you were making
movies for the actual drive-ins like
Randy was saying the outdoor theaters
with big screens and fields people in
cars sometimes watching the movie
sometimes doing other things what were
the what were the specific strategies
that that you use to make movies for for
drive-in theaters primarily i was making
films for the youth market the major
studios were of course making films with
their stars it takes generally years for
a star to become established so they
were making films say with a 50 year old
leading man and a 40 year old leading
lady in the audience was 18 19 and 20
and I felt the thing to do since I
couldn't afford those stars anyway was
simply to make youth oriented films in
the genres that were fairly popular we
did teenage action films we did science
fiction we did horror we did a number of
comedies and we started a number of
actors we were at the beginning of their
careers since we couldn't go with stars
we picked young people that we thought
were very good people like Jack
Nicholson and Charles Bronson at the
beginning and then a number of others
you broke the mold for marketing movies
and drive-ins and other ways too I mean
you actually put in marburg men in a
drivin didn't you yes a Meyer Bergman's
academy award-winning film cries and
whispers we played in the usual art
houses you generally started in New York
and Los Angeles to get the reviews and
then you spread out to the major cities
and the college towns around the country
and that was it it was the art house
circuit we have done that fall was
coming on and the drive-ins were were
open in the fall but they didn't do much
business because the weather was turning
and most studios didn't want to put
pictures in the drive-ins at that time
and I knew the dry beans who were
looking for films and I thought why not
put cries and whispers in a drive-in and
see what happens and it really said you
can't put an art film in a drive-in and
everybody was totally delighted because
we did average business and I don't
think you've really seen cries and
whispers until you've seen it on a
driving yestreen the way actually I got
a letter from Ingmar Bergman thanking me
or bringing his film to an audience he
had never expected to reach